Patti, I was just cutting my buns.
(audience laughs)
Oh, you just cutting your buns?
Okay, I have a wrap.
A low calorie wrap,
because sometimes the bread is a little bread,
you know, sometimes we don't need it
but I'm gonna do it on a flat wrap, okay?
Okay.
(pan sizzling)
So this is a...
(pans clanking)
I've already cooked the onions,
the vidalia onions
(pan sizzling)
with the steak,
and I also put my cheese on the bottom of my wrap
so that it can melt properly.
And guess what else to go up?
And you can have tomatoes, pickles, raw onions.
I have cooked them into my steak,
and I have habanero peppers and they're hot as heck.
(audience laughs)
And jalapenos.
And I have sea flakes, you know, the red pepper flakes.
And I have some real hot sauce that sometimes I use,
and ketchup if you prefer ketchup,
you can do that too, okay?
Okay, I'm gonna put this on mine.
Only one cause they're hot as heck, okay?
And then I'm gonna roll mine. (laughs)
I've always wanted to learn
how to make a Philly Cheesesteak
and I was lucky enough to go to Philadelphia once
and eat in like, a proper flat top
awesome, like, Philly Cheesesteak dive
and it was everything that I'd hoped it would be.
Well, you're doing it right today.
So then I'll cut this wrap-
Patti, I heard um, that...
you knew Richard Pryor, is this true?
Oh God, we toured a lot together,
Richard Pryor and myself,
and he always felt as though
he wasn't paying me enough cash,
so he would always give me gifts.
He sent beautiful diamonds to my home,
and on the road we were in Detroit
and he wanted to buy his aunt a car.
And like he said, "Help me pick out a car for my aunt."
I said, "What color is her hair?"
He says like gray, bluish gray.
So I found this beautiful blue, soft blue
like my fingernails, this color car,
and I sat in it, and he says, "Sit in it."
I said, "Okay."
He said, "Now here's the keys."
He said, "This is your new car."
(Drew gasps)
I said, "Richard,
I don't drive."
And my husband's gon' kill me because we have two cars,
and why is he going to say, "Where'd you get that car from?"
"Richard Pryor",
(audience laughs)
say, "Because he loves me."
(laughing continues)
And so, we ended up with three cars
and he was such a wonderful man.
And the funniest man I know. (laughs)
I've...
Yes, so..
I've always had-
That was wonderful.
a thing for comedians,
because I do feel like they're healers.
And I was such a big-
They are.
Richard Pryor fan growing up.
So I had to ask because he is such a legend.
He (stutters)
Yes.
And now my cheese is melted...
Oh, Patty...
Yes, it looks really good!
That looks perfect!
You should put some sea peppers, some real hot flakes on
if you have them, or some habanero peppers,
and ketchup if you like.
Okay, I want peppers, banana peppers,
cheese and meat.
Wow! Nice. Okay.
Ready?
Well, just do it.
Okay. Ready?
Hmm, it's good.
Yeah. It's really good.
Let me hear you chew.
How do you chew?
(audience laughs)
How do you chew, girl?
Well, it's even worse, Patti.
I'm not kidding, I don't even care.
I'm like-
(audience laughing)
(Patti laughing)
Just chew, honey. Eat it!
It's so good with the wrap.
Oh my God, I'm so...
That's so good!
Really good.
It is good.
Is this weird that I'm going around the top
like a typewriter?
(audience laughs)
No, it's not weird.
You're chewing it the way you have to, honey.
Do you know what my very favorite food is on planet Earth?
What?
It's macaroni and cheese.
Ooh, I gotcha.
I'mma need somebody pass it to me.
So...
Yes!
I love macaroni, and I have some for you.
I'm so excited
Thank you.
I'm gonna get to try
the very famous Patti LaBelle
(Patti cheers)
macaroni and cheese right now.
See?
I'm puttin' my hair back.
Okay, honey.
Do you want me to put some on the plate for you?
Oh, I'm eating right out of the pan, Patti.
(audience laughs)
(Patti laughs)
You're my kind of girl. Go ahead.
And it's so good.
I'm not bragging,
(spoon clacks)
but it's awesome.
This is exactly how I love macaroni and cheese.
And when it deviates from this,
I feel like it's not macaroni and cheese.
You completely nailed it.
This is exactly what macaroni and cheese...
This is the dream.
(Patti laughs)
This is the Everest of mac and cheese.
Oh, you're so sweet.
Go with a little more and get it, honey.
(audience laughs)
'Cause this show is sellin'.
(Patti laughs)
And, no meal would be complete without shoving
another bite of food.
(audience laughs)
I'm so excited I get to try your sweet potato pie
that sells 36,000 pies a day.
Oh...
Yay!
You've never tasted it, right?
No, this is my first!
Oh, girl.
Okay, ready?
You're my kind of girl.
Oh wow.
Aww...
The cinnamon...
Wow.
and the spices.
It's so incredibly flavorful.
You taste it, right?
Oh wow, thank you.
Your food, it is love,
and you can taste it and you can feel it.
This was so much fun.
Thank you so much for having me on your wonderful show.
Oh my goodness-
Thank you, sweetie.
Thank you Patti LaBelle
so much...
(audience claps)
Patti's Good Life frozen foods are available
at Walmart and other stores as well,
and Patti's Philly Cheesesteak recipe
is gonna be on our website.
(clapping continues)
I can't recommend it more.
Yay!
(audience clapping)
Patti,
(Patti chuckles)
thank you.
(upbeat music)